THE TWO CASES BETWEEN FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN WITH THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IS DIFFERENT.
WE WANT TO SEE HOW THIS IS
RESONATING WITH VOTERS.
THAT'S WHY WE ASSEMBLED THIS
PANEL OF DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS,
AND INDEPENDENTS TO HEAR WHAT
THEY THINK.
>> I'M GOING TO START WITH ALAN.
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK WHEN YOU
HEARD ABOUT THE BIDEN DOCUMENTS
AND HOW THE WHITE HOUSE IS
HANDLING IT?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS SHOCKING
ABOUT HOW THE WHITE HOUSE WAS
HANDLING IT.
I THOUGHT THEY HANDLED THE
SITUATION APPROPRIATE.
THEY WERE COOPERATING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, AND THEY
DID THINGS THE RIGHT WAY UNLIKE
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WHERE
THEY BASICALLY HID AWAY AND HAD
TO GET A SUBPOENA FOR THE
DOCUMENTS TO BE CAME UP WITH.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HANDLED THE
SITUATION CORRECTLY.
THEY TURNED OVER THE DOCUMENTS
TO THE APPROPRIATE PLACES WHEN
IT WAS TIME AND WHEN THEY NEEDED
TO BE TURNED OVER.
>> SO EDWARD, YOU HEARD WHAT
AYLON HAD TO SAY THERE.
YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN, SERVED IN
THE MILITARY FOR 23 YEARS, WHAT
DO YOU THINK OF BOTH CASES?
>> I THINK NOT NECESSARILY
LOOKING AT HOW THEY'RE HANDLING
THINGS DIFFERENTLY BUT WHAT ARE
THE SIMILARITIES?
AND THE SIMILARITIES ARE THE
FACT THAT CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
WERE MISHANDLED.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER -- NO ONE
IS ABOVE THE LAW, RIGHT.
AND THE RULES APPLY TO EVERYONE.
THERE'S NOWHERE IN THE RULES OF
HANDLING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
THAT SAYS THAT THEY GET TO BE
STORED IN A GARAGE IN YOUR
PERSONAL RESIDENCE FOR MORE THAN
SIX YEARS AND NO ONE KNOWS WHERE
THEY'RE AT, WHAT THEY CONTAIN,
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN SAY, OH,
WELL, AFTER THE CRIME WAS
COMMITTED, THE PERSON THEN
TURNED THEMSELVES IN AND DID THE
RIGHT THING.
OR FELL ON THEIR SWORD.
NO.
THE RULES WERE BROKEN AND BOTH
CASES NEED TO BE HANDLED AS
SUCH.
THAT THE RULES WERE BROKEN AND
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHY THAT
HAPPENED AND HOW IT HAPPENED.
>> DO YOU FEEL THE STAMAME WAY,U
HAVE THE SAME ENERGY FOR THE
DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT SAID HE DIDN'T
WANT TO TURN BACK OVER AND HE
HID AND CHANGED.
>> HERE'S HOW I FEEL ABOUT THAT.
AND THAT IS, THE NATIONAL
SECURITY IS BIGGER THAN ANY ONE
PERSON, RIGHT.
BIGGER THAN ANY PRESIDENT, VICE
PRESIDENT, OR ANY OF THAT.
AND SO, WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THESE DOCUMENTS, IF THEY'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE IN A CERTAIN --
IN SOMEONE'S POSSESSION, THEN
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
SO WE HAVE TO FOLLOW THE RULES.
>> GREAT.
SO JEN, I WANT TO BRING YOU IN
HERE, YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT, YOU
THINK THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT JOE BIDEN DID AND
WHAT DONALD TRUMP DID REGARDING
THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
SO HOW DO YOU SEE IT?
>> SO I DEFINITELY AGREE THAT
WHILE IT IS WRONG THAT BOTH
PRESIDENTS HAD ACCESS TO THESE
DOCUMENTS.
THE WAY THEY HANDLED IT, SHOWS
THE DISTINCT DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE TWO.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TIMELINE
WITH DONALD TRUMP AND THESE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES AND RECORDS
ADMINISTRATION WAS THE ONE THAT
REACHED OUT TO TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS
TO LET THEM KNOW WE'RE MISSING
DOCUMENTS.
LET'S COOPERATE, GET THIS GOING.
IT TOOK THE BETTER PART OF A
YEAR THAT TRUMP REFUSED TO HAND
OVER THE DOCUMENTS AND THAT'S
WHAT LED TO THE RAID AT
MAR-A-LAGO AND A SPECIAL COUNSEL
HAS BEEN APPOINTED, IT'S GONE
THROUGH THE PROCEDURES BUT TRUMP
HAS HELD ON FOR DEAR LIFE AND
SAID NO, AND STUCK HIS HEAD IN
THE SAND ABOUT IT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BIDEN
TIMELINE, THESE DOCUMENTS WERE
IDENTIFIED BY PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
ATTORNEYS IN NOVEMBER AND THEY
IMMEDIATELY NOTIFIED THE NARA
ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS.
AN INVESTIGATION IS HELD,
SPECIAL COUNSEL APPOINTED,
COOPERATED FULLY AND WORKED TO
MAKE EVERYTHING RIGHT.
>> WE HEARD FROM DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM AN
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE I WONDER IF
INDEPENDENTS FEEL THE SAME WAY.
IF PEOPLE REALLY READ THAT MUCH
INTO THE NUANCES HERE.
IF THEY THINK BOTH PEOPLE DID
SOMETHING WRONG.
LYNDA, LETS BRING IN YOU AS AN
INDEPENDENT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL BIDEN IS
HANDLING THE DOCUMENTS?
HAS IT CHANGED HOW YOU SEE HIM?
>> FROM WHAT I CAN TELL HERE IN
TEXAS, THE PRESIDENT HAS HANDLED
THIS BETTER THAN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
AND THE REAL QUESTION IS, SO
WHAT?
THE INDEPENDENTS ARE SICK AND
TIRED OF ALL THE GAMESMANSHIP,
GOTCHA POLITICS.
INVESTIGATIVEDA SHOWS, IT GOES
AND ON.
WHY CAN'T WE HAVE DEPOLITICIZED
GOVERNMENT WHY ARE WE CONSTANTLY
RUNNING A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
IT'S ENDLESS WAR INTERNAL TO OUR
COUNTRY AND IT'S GETTING OLD.
>> MY QUESTION WAS, DOES IT
CHANGE HOW YOU VIEW OR HOW YOU
SEE THE CURRENT PRESIDENT, THE
DOCUMENT ISSUE?
>> NOT REALLY.
BECAUSE BIDEN IS A VERY
EXPERIENCED POLITICIAN.
AND HE'S GOT GOOD ADVISERS AND,
YOU KNOW, THE DEMOCRATS -- THE
DEMOCRATS GENERALLY GET THESE
THINGS BETTER BECAUSE THEY
UNDERSTAND GOVERNANCE BETTER
THAN THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
BUT DOES IT MAKE HIM ANY BETTER
TO GOVERN?
I THINK THAT BOTH PARTIES ARE
TAKING US DOWN THESE RABBIT
HOLES THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
REAL TIRED OF.
>> DO YOU THINK TRUMP OR BIDEN,
IF THEY ARE FOUND TO HAVE BROKEN
THE LAW, SHOULD THEY FACE
CONSEQUENCES?
>> I THINK WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
THE LAW, THEY SHOULD.
HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT
THIS IDEA THAT BIDEN IS HANDLING
IT BETTER, I KIND OF -- I THINK
IT'S KIND OF SILLY BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW HE CONTROLS THE NARRATIVE.
THEY CONTROL THE NARRATIVE AT
THE DOJ AT HIS FINGERTIPS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
ALL THIS.
BUT WHEN YOU MAKE A SPECTACLE
OUT OF, YOU KNOW -- SO TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION, YES, IT SHOULD
BE.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, THEY
MADE A SPECTACLE OUT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR POLITICAL
REASONS LIKE LINDA WAS SAYING.
THEY'RE TRYING TO TAKE HIM DOWN
THE RABBIT HOLE FOR CAMPAIGN
PURPOSES AND NOW IT'S HAPPENING
TO HIM.
THEY GET TO CONTROL THE DOJ,
EVERYTHING THEY'RE SAYING.
SO OF COURSE THE DOJ IS SAYING
YEAH, THEY'VE BEEN VERY
COOPERATIVE.
YEAH, THAT'S THEIR SIDE.
THEY'RE ON THEIR OWN SIDE SAYING
THAT.
SO I DON'T REALLY TRUST THE
NARRATIVE COMING OUT ABOUT THAT.
>> ELAINE, LET ME BRING YOU IN
AS AN INDEPENDENT.
YOU VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN IN 2020.
IF JOE BIDEN ANNOUNCES THAT HE
IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN
IN 2024, WOULD THIS BE A REASON
FOR YOU NOT TO VOTE FOR HIM
AGAIN?
>> ALONG WITH A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS.
WE NEED SOMEBODY ELSE.
I MEAN, WE'VE GOT -- WE'VE
HAD -- RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS LIKE
THE TWO FRONT RUNNERS ARE
BASICALLY A REPLAY OF 2020, AND
WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THIS.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE YOU WANT TO
CHANGE.
I'M WONDERING IF THE DOCUMENT
THING WAS THAT.
WERE YOU THINKING THIS BEFORE
THE DOCUMENT ISSUE OR IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT -- DID THE
DOCUMENT ISSUE LEAD YOU TO THE
POINT YOU'RE AT NOW WE NEED A
CHANGE, WE NEED DIFFERENT
CANDIDATES IN 2024?
>> THE DOCUMENT ISSUE
REINFORCES, STRONGLY REINFORCES
THAT SENTIMENT.
>> LET'S SAY, JUST FOR PURPOSES
OF THIS INTERVIEW, IF IT IS JOE
BIDEN AND DONALD TRUMP IN 2024,
WOULD YOU -- YOU VOTED FOR BIDEN
IN 2020, WHO WOULD YOU VOTE FOR
IN 2024, IF THE TWO CANDIDATES
ARE THE SAME, TRUMP VERSUS
BIDEN?
>> I WOULD NOT VOTE FOR TRUMP, I
KNOW THAT MUCH.
I WOULD BE REALLY HOPING THERE'S
A THIRD ALTERNATIVE.
>> OKAY.
SO THE DOCUMENT ISSUE FOR YOU
REALLY REINFORCED THAT YOU THINK
THERE SHOULD BE A CHANGE.
>> IT REINFORCES, YES.
>> THANK YOU ELAINE, EDWARD, TIE
ARE YOU, ELAN, JEN, LINDA.
BE WELL.